jetsetter designer self-made man Renzo
Rosso is worth more than 3 billion
dollars has been called the jeans genius
these are my initial that was my little
pleasure when I was 15 now 58 friends er
has built an empire see-sawing his first
pair of bell-bottom jeans as a young boy
he still considers himself an outsider
but he's at home here at Diesel's
headquarters in northern Italy who is
this stupid attire that come to sell
development in the country where the
name is born echo CLG labelled erotic
America pain sake this is your mark
Americana pinned Amy Granderson friends
are launched diesel in 1978 but the
turning point came in the mid 80s
when he launched his signature stressed
denim look it was a huge success diesel
now has 400 stores in 80 countries and
is just one of Renzo's family of brands
this is the data that I arrived my first
day that I sitting on this place but he
has no desire to become like the French
fashion behemoth LVMH you'll become a
self ego
I wear a CEO name
this is the righto Niki assemble to the
pew kara wanted twins I always thought
to bring in fresh young talent Nicola
former Katy was formerly Lady Gaga's
personal designer
now he's Diesel's artistic director how
did you guys meet
Renzo knows to keep diesel cool needs to
step back and allow young talent to come
forward so I was showing them he says
it's about finding people to replace his
foolishness cooled up
Angus Bennett